les premiers pas de l'euro dans la vie
quotidienne des français avec dès ce
matin dans quelques grandes surfaces la
possibilité de payer ses achats par
chèque ou par carte bleue une initiative
à la fois pédagogique et pratique qui ne
soulevait pas encore l' enthousiasme
chez la plupart des commerçants
jean-paul chapelle jeanne grégoire c'est
là où le consommateur dit madame
mademoiselle peut-être j'aimerais payés
en euros premiers paiements en euros par
carte bancaire dans cet hypermarché près
de paris michel edouard leclerc a déjà
réactualisé 40000 pris avec le taux
officiel connu depuis 48 heures
l'épicier profite de l'occasion pour
faire sa publicité il ose même donné une
leçon de pédagogie au ministre de
l'économie
tout le monde va savoir assez vite qu un
smig ses 1000 euros qu'un litre
d'essence et un euro
vous voyez chacun va pas se faire comme
maman dominique strauss kahn a parlé de
la baguette à 0,70 doit l'acheter à
neuilly chez nous ça va être à 0,30 bon
si le patron du magasin paye aujourd'hui
en euros ses propres clients eux
préfèrent encore la monnaie nationale
tant que c'est pas de monnaie courant
qu'on peut toucher tous les jours celle
entre l'intérêt
pas d'intérêt dans l'immédiat mais dans
trois ans une obligation
en france cinq cent soixante mille
commerçants sont équipés d'un terminal
de paiement électronique et pour la
moitié d'entre eux cette machine est
déjà compatible avec l'euro on va taper
comme d'habitude je vais y aller taper
au franc et l'expression du ticket se
fera en français et en euros par
conséquent il n'y a pas de modifications
pour vivre jouer l'étape programmé pour
prendre
pour prendre les francs dans leur grande
majorité les commerçants n'ont encore
fait aucune démarche au groupement des
cartes bancaires dernier test ultime
contrôle pour le client le basculement
en euros doit être simple comme un jeu
d'enfant il n'y a pas besoin de changer
de carte des 30 millions de cartes
bancaires aujourd'hui en circulation
sont tout à fait aptes à fonctionner en
euros a pas besoin non plus d'avoir un
compte en euros vous touchez à rien vous
gardez votre compte et votre carte
encore faut-il que le commerçant
l'acceptent sinon les accros de l'euro
pourront tenter un autre paiement par
chèque mais dans ce cas il faut un
chéquier spéciale